>> GREG GUTFELD HAS A BIG AND
IMPORTANT CHANGE IN HIS LIFE.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
HMM?
HOW'S THAT FOR A RESEMBLANCE?
>> SAY HELLO TO GUS GOT FOULED,
AN ADORABLE
PUG --
JESSICA WHO WILL HAVE ONE.
I GOT A GIFT FOR GUS.
THERE IS A HALLOWEEN BANDANNA,
AN OCTOPUS, AND THIS FOR WHEN HE
GETS OLDER.
IT'S HIS FIRST UNIFORM SOCCER
BALL.
>> IT STRANGE.
I HAVEN'T SLEPT BECAUSE ALL HE
DOES -- WE ARE CRATE TRAINING
HIM.
ALL HE DOES IS SCREAM IN THIS
DEMONIC WAY OLD.
HE'S TINY, BUT IT IS SCREAMING.
I LOOK LIKE A MESS.
>> YOU ARE A NEW PARENTS.
>> I NOTICED A CHANGE IN YOU
ALREADY.
>> BY THE WAY, THOSE ARE NOT MY
LEGS.
>> USE SHAVED.
>> HAVE TO SLEEP IN THERE.
>> HE DOES THAT SO YOU CAN'T
MOVE.
>> THE GREAT THING I LEARNED
ABOUT DOGS IS THEIR POOP AND PEE
DOESN'T SMELL.
I FORGET ABOUT WASHING MY HANDS
AFTER A WHILE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S STILL TOXIC.
>> I HAVE GOOD ADVICE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE A ROOM
ABOVE, BUT IF YOU DO, NEVER TURN
IT ON WITH THE PUPPY OUT OF THE
HOUSE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS?
>> IF THE PUPPY HAS AN
ACCIDENT...
>> OH, NO.
>> YOUR HOUSE WILL SMELL.
>> HAS THAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> IT MAY HAS.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> AND RUMBA WANT TO GIVE YOU A
NEW ONE.
>> DO HAVE ADVICE?
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
WHY DID YOU GO WITH THE FRENCH
BULLDOG?
THERE IS A RESEMBLANCE.
>> THAT'S THE FIRST THING MY
WIFE SAID.
"LOOKS JUST LIKE YOU."
KAT TIMPF, THE BLONDE LADY FROM
THE "GUTFELD SHOW," THEIR DOG
IS --
I DO NOT COME OUT DIFFERENT MOM
DOGS ARE ALL SLUTS, THEY SLEEP
WITH EVERYBODY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I LEARNED -- I HAVE GOOD
ADVICE.
THESE MONKS RAISED GERMAN
SHEPHERDS TO BE SERVICE DOGS.
IN THE BOOK, THEY HAVE A TIP.
WHEN HE'S OLDER, YOU WANT TO
TAKE HIM TO A PLACE THAT IS
UNFAMILIAR, A WOODED AREA.
>> FOR GREG?
TAKE THEM TO OUR CHURCH.
>> HOW DARE YOU?
>> YOU WANT TO TAKE HIM OFF THE
LEASH AND HAVE HIM SIT AROUND
YOU.
>> YOU HAVE HIM DIVE AROUND THE
TREE, WAIT A MOMENT FOR HIM TO
GET NERVOUS WAITING FOR YOU, AND
THEN STEP OUT AND SAY "I'M RIGHT
HERE," AND HE WILL NEVER TAKE
HIS EYES OFF OF YOU AND IT HELPS
A LOT.
>> JOE WILL, ANOTHER PIECE OF
ADVICE.
I REMEMBER THIS FROM SCOTT ADAMS
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
DOGS BARKING, THAT THEY ARE IN
THE SAME LANGUAGE AS YOU.
THE BEST ANALOGY TO A PUPPY OR
DOG BARKING IS WHEN YOU ARE
PRESSING A DOORBELL AND NOBODY
IS HOME OR YOU ARE PRESSING A
BUTTON TO GET A CANDY BAR OUT OF
THE VENDING MACHINE.
IT IS NOT -- IT'S JUST PUSHING A
BUTTON.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THAT --
>> IT PUSHES MY BUTTONS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAD TO GET JOHNNY TO ASK
SOMEONE IF THEY COULD HAVE
RICKY --
[LAUGHTER]
>> JESSE!
>> APPARENTLY THAT IS CONSIDERED
BARBARIC.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JESSICA, ANY ADVICE OF WHO IS
RAISING A BABY?
>> THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAD A DOG WHEN I WAS YOUNGER,
BUT IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH
ATTENTION THEY ARE GETTING ON
THE STREETS, THAT DOG DOWN TO
THE CORNER.
>> WALKED ONTO A PET SHOP AND
HAD THEM.
EVERYBODY THERE -- THE FAME GOES
AWAY FROM YOU TO THIS DOG --
PEOPLE ARE TELLING ME THAT A
CHANGE THEIR LIFE, BUT NOW IT'S
JUST THE DOG.
>> PEOPLE SAY TO ME --
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHEN I AM ALONE, IT'S FANS
FROM SIX TO 5-70-YEAR-OLD
LADIES, BUT WHEN I GOT THE DOG
IT'S ALL THE MODEL